what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today we're going to be
covering the strongest heroes in one
punch man
except of course Saitama who has yet to
be placed in the s-class for more one
punch man videos like this one be sure
to one punch that like button if you
haven't be sure to subscribe and ring
that notification bell so you don't miss
any new videos there will be some
spoilers in this video now without
further ado let's jump into it starting
with the 17th ranked s-class hero puddi
puddi prisoner he is the 33 year old
insanely muscular prison boss who loves
Sailor Moon and boyfriend sweaters
according to data book he scored an 8
out of 10 in stamina a foreign
intelligence a 6 in justice and 8 in
endurance a 7 in power a 7 in popularity
and 8 in effectiveness and an 8 in
fighting ability like a conventional
superhero Booty pooty prisoner has super
strength endurance and speed
he uses his angel style to defeat
opponents he's recently unlocked the
move angel bristle armor where he grows
hair all over his body which
dramatically increases his defense with
this new defense he was practically
unfazed by neons sharp claws even though
he's threat level dragon yawn even
starts running away from him the move
angel crawl allows him to swim through
stone like it was water despite how
emotional and naked he usually is he is
definitely a force to be reckoned with
tank top master is the 16th ranked
s-class hero who heads the tank top army
here's a quote that captures his
philosophy tank top is the source of
strength if I can bring out even more
potential of the tank top if I become a
man who is worthy of the tank top then I
can defeat even psychic power and quote
according to the data book he scored a 9
and stamina a 5 and intelligence a 7
injustice and eight endurance and eight
in power and eight in popularity and
eight in effectiveness and an 8 in
fighting ability similarly to put in
putting prisoner
tank top master is a physical type
possessing super strength speed and
durability most of tank tops moves
aren't very complicated he uses his
strength to deliver attack
and punches he can also punch the ground
so hard that he begins to crack and
throws his opponent off balance
however he couldn't defeat the human
monster gato the 17 year old bad aka
metal bat is the 15th ranked s-class
hero like all manly men he values
fighting spirit above logic he wields
his signature bat has a tough persona of
a delinquent and even claims that threat
level dragon monsters are nothing to him
but he has a soft spot for his little
sister when it appeared like he could
have got the finishing blow on gato
his sister showed up and he stopped the
attack because he promised never to
expose her to violence he's a weapons
type hero and his stats are as follows
he got an 8 in stamina
III and intelligence a 7 in justice and
8 in endurance a 9 in power a 7 in
popularity and Eden effectiveness and a
9 in fighting ability in addition to the
usual super strength metal bat possesses
a fighting spirit that increases his
physical abilities as battles dragged on
and he takes more damage by the end of
his fight with gato he likely would have
been able to finish him off if he landed
one solid blow but he stopped because of
his sister many people were impressed by
the power of his swings including Garo
superalloy dark shine and bang it is
suggested that metal bat could be ranked
even higher but like Saitama he doesn't
care about his hero rank the
nineteen-year-old jenos aka demon cyborg
is currently ranked 14th his family was
killed by a cyborg and so he became a
cyborg of Justice so he could get his
revenge one day in contrast to his son
say Saitama he has the cool hair and the
look that you'd expect from your
stereotypical superhero jenos tends to
be a very serious student and greatly
respects his mentor the much more
carefree Saitama according to the data
book he got a 9 and stamina 8 7 in
intelligence a 7 in justice a 9 in
endurance and 8 in power and 8 in
popularity a 6 in effectiveness and a 9
for fighting ability he is a
machine-type fighter
Genisys cyborg body is strong enough to
lift a truck with one hand and fast
enough to move quicker than the speed of
sound as a cyborg he can also get cool
grades that can help him in battle Kiva
contains incinerate cannons and his
palms that can shoot explosive fire
attacks at his enemies and he can use
boosters located in his elbows and
shoulders to accelerate his movements
and strengthen his attacks the 13th
ranked s-class hero is the 25 year old
flashy flash he's from the same ninja
village and was from the same graduating
class as speedo sound sonic he's a
serious dude with feminine features and
he is best known for his insane speed
like Saitama he believes that training
rather than natural talent is the key to
becoming strong and he believes that the
only ones you can entice with money are
those whose power is weaker than money
itself flashy flash dropping more
knowledge than the other flash ever
could he scored an 8 in stamina he's 6
and intelligence he 5 in justice the
lowest s-class hero score known in this
category a 7 in endurance a perfect 10
in power and 8 in popularity and 8 in
effectiveness and a 9 in fighting
ability he is a weapon type fighter and
mainly uses his katana to fight flashy
flashes ultimate technique is flashy
slash where he uses his incredible speed
with his katana in order to cut his
opponents in half he used this technique
to defeat two dragon level villains
he is the first s-class hero to be shown
defeating even one dragon level villain
on his own he is definitely one of my
favorite s-class heroes and I hope to
see a lot more of him in the future the
12th ranked s-class hero is watchdog man
a very mysterious dude whose age has yet
to be revealed you wouldn't think that a
bored looking man in a dog suit would be
strong but you'd be wrong he keeps the
dog suit on even when he bathes and is
always acting like a dog he's
territorial and sticks to fighting
monsters in Kew City he beat over 30
monsters before without even breaking a
sweat
he is extremely fast and powerful when
got a challenge him he easily beat Gaara
who only survived because he managed to
leave his territory and thus watch dog
stop chasing after him he is a physical
type of fighter but his other statistics
remain a mystery the 11th ranked hero is
the 27 year old super alloy dark shine
he is a bald muscular dude who is always
the shiniest guy in the room he trained
his body to be harder than steel
according to the data book he scored a
tenant stamina a 5 and intelligence a 6
and justice a 9 and endurance and 8 in
power a 7 in popularity a 7 in
effectiveness and a 9 in fighting
ability he is a physical type of fighter
his physical strength and durability are
considered to be top-tier even among the
S Class Heroes his body couldn't even be
scratched by a tiger level monsters
drills even though they were as tough as
steel in that place we have the very
very large pig God whose age remains
undisclosed
he's not your conventional hero he will
take the shortest route even if it means
crashing through buildings and he eats
his monster opponents he proved to be
immune to a significant amount of poison
when he fought I sight a demon level
monster he also has the ability to
stretch his body so that he can even
consume opponents bigger than himself
according to the data book his scores
are all a mystery except for
effectiveness in which he scored an 8
out of 10 in 9th place we have dr knight
yet another mysterious hero with an
undisclosed age we do not know if dr
knight is a cyborg or robot but we do
know that he is like an edgier Robocop
he uses a box-like transforming object
for battle it can seemingly change it to
anything he can use it to gain
horse-like legs to increase a speed or
he can use it to create a blade of light
that can cut through monsters in one
swipe he's a calm and calculating
fighter he tries to collect data from
monsters rather than simply disposing of
them as fast as possible he insists on
killing monsters who have seen him fight
and he is willing to torture them before
he kills them to get the information he
wants this is probably why so much about
him remains a mystery he goes out of his
way to keep his abilities a secret as
far as his stats go all we know is that
he scored a 7 in popularity and a 6 in
effectiveness
in eighth place we have zombie man one
of the coolest heroes in the series he
was created by the house of evolution
where he was experimented on for a long
time
he's a detective who cannot be killed
he'll just regenerate
he tends to have a pretty bleak view of
the world but you can't blame him when
you consider the torturous experiments
he must have undergone and the amount of
times he's almost died only to
regenerate again he is a weapons type of
fighter using guns machetes axes and so
on he scored a tenant stamina in fact he
lasted 140 hours fighting against a
monster before a six and intelligence a
six injustice a perfect tenant endurance
a six in power and eight in popularity
and Aiden effectiveness and a nine in
fighting ability although he's arguably
one of the physically weakest S Class
Heroes he manages to prevail against
strong monsters like pure blood through
perseverance pure blood Gabe zombie man
200 mortal wounds but he regenerated and
ended up beating the vampire and his 30
monster underlings when it comes to
fights he's a marathon runner not a
sprinter and that makes him a very
interesting character in a world filled
with extremely fast and overpowered
heroes in seventh place we have the 29
year old king also referred to as the
strongest man in the world he is
secretly the weakest of the S Class
Heroes yet because of dumb luck he has
developed a reputation of being the
strongest even the hard to impress Tatsu
lucky respects him and that's saying a
lot although he usually seems calm and
threatening he's actually a fear-filled
otaku who likes playing dating
simulation games although Saitama is
usually the strongest fighter around
King crushes him when it comes to
fighting in video games the here
association classified King as a
physical type of fighter and they gave
him perfect scores in every category a
10 in stamina intelligence justice
endurance power popularity effectiveness
and fighting ability although King is
pretty weak compared to other heroes his
legend precedes him and his intimidating
look gets many monsters to give up
before Kings lack of power is exposed
people think the king engine a sound
that comes from Kings heartbeat when he
is afraid and experiencing anxiety is
actually the sound of his blood loss and
that the king engine is so powerful that
could shake the earth King does have
things going for him though he is a
master bluffer a master gamer and
experiences ridiculous amounts of good
luck so that monsters are somehow
defeated near his presence and he ends
up getting credit for their defeat an
interesting fact about him is that
people think that he got his scars from
a fight to the death against a god level
monster but in reality he got it from a
tiger level monster called octo claw man
king just cried until a younger Saitama
with hair beat the monster in sixth
place we have metal knight aka dr. McCoy
yet another mysterious figure he fights
using remote-controlled robots while he
remains safe at a distant location not
having to risk his life he is a very
self-interested man and is more
concerned about testing out his new
rockets on a meteor than saving the
people of Zee city he can be cold and
pragmatic to the point of ruthlessness
and is willing to give up the life of a
child hostage if it would mean the Swift
destruction of the monster Association
hideout and its monsters he is afraid of
the evil lurking in the shadows of the
monster Association and is caring enough
to warn child Emperor about it metal
knight is classified as a machine type
of fighter and although some of his
stats remain a mystery we know that he
scored a perfect 10 in intelligence he's
7 in popularity a 9 in effectiveness and
a 10 in fighting ability even though he
fights with his genius level brain
rather than physical strength his robots
are extremely strong
according to guru guru he is one of only
four heroes who can beat the dragon
level monster called Elder centipede
because of his vast and secret military
might his intelligence is also used to
build a hero associations defense
systems and to rebuild the hero
associations HQ once it is destroyed
dr. buffet is confirmed to have at least
100 fighting robots and his military
arsenal is so large and powerful at the
hero Association fierce deity of him
ever turning on that in fifth place we
have the 10 year-old child Emperor the
youngest hero in the hero Association
much like metal knight his genius level
brain is the key to child emperor's
power according to the data book child
Emperor scored a foreign stamina a
perfect 10 in intelligence and 8 in
justice III and endurance a 6 in power
and 8 in popularity and
in effectiveness and a 9 in fighting
ability he's a weapons type of fighter
his backpack can do a lot including help
him fly or battle robotic tentacles come
out of it like he was little dock off
from spider-man which he can use to hurt
or kill enemy monsters he has many other
weapons including defensive barriers and
a mecha that can launch what looks like
an extremely strong command man the
combination of his intellect and wide
variety of weapons helped him defeat the
dragon level monster Phoenix man who
would have thought that the brave giant
mecha wouldn't work while a tickle
tickle bug number 1 would do the trick
in 4th place we have the 37 year old
atomic samurai aka kamikaze aka the
world's strongest swordsman he's pretty
full of himself and he refused to shake
hands with Saitama when they met saying
that he only accepts the strong and that
he'll greet sytem up properly when he
makes it to s-class when fighting
against rhino wrestler a demon level
monster he was able to cut him to pieces
so fast that no one saw what happened
and the Rhino could even keep talking
for a few seconds after he'd been cut
that right there is an epic swordsman
atomic samurai is obviously a weapons
type of fighter those weapons being
swords he scored a 9 in stamina a
foreign intelligence a 6 injustice in
Eden endurance a perfect tenant power
and eight in popularity and eight and
effectiveness and a 9 in fighting
ability the name atomic samurai itself
simultaneously speaks to his precise
atom cutting swordsmanship and his
overwhelming nuclear level power in
third place we have the 81 year old
silver Fang aka bang bang and his
brother bomb were called the two
greatest masters of the martial arts
world by gato
he is often serious unafraid of dragon
level monsters and has a good amount of
moral integrity unlike some other heroes
on this list he cares about his former
disciple gato even after all the
horrible things he did silver Fang is a
physical type of fighter and he scored a
9 and stamina a 6 and intelligence he's
7 and justice a 9 and endurance a
perfect 10 in power a 7 in popularity a
9 and effectiveness and a 9 and fighting
ability like a lot of superheroes silver
Fang has super strength super speed and
super
ability but his level is even impressive
among S Class Heroes Bank created his
own martial art style called water
stream rock smashing fist that he uses
to great effect don't let his old age
fool you he's still strong enough to
beat dragon level monsters and the
extremely muscular super alloy dark
shine in second place we have the 28
year old tornado of terror
aka tot Tsubaki she is a much stronger
half of the psychic sisters and the sub
proclaimed teacher of her younger sister
boo boo ki
tatsumaki is at tsundere she doesn't
care about being rude or disrespectful
and she'll be quick to call you a baka
she acts cold towards people but at the
same time she can also be really caring
like with her sister she's usually
extremely arrogant and has little
tolerance for people who she deems to be
incompetent but even she respects King
she is a psychic type of fighter she
scored a 5 in stamina a 7 in
intelligence a 7 injustice and eight
endurance a 9 in power a 9 in popularity
a perfect tenant effectiveness and a
perfect tenant fighting ability although
she looks young and is often
underestimated as a result
tatsumaki is the most powerful Esper in
the entire one punishment series and the
highest ranking hero that we've actually
seen in first place we have the
middle-aged blast
he is shrouded more mystery than any
other s-class hero we haven't even seen
his face let alone his fighting
abilities glass is considered to be the
first hero like Saitama blast considers
being a hero to be more of a hobby he
beat the dragon level elder centipede in
the past and the leader of the ninja
village who was regarded as the most
powerful ninja to ever exist he was the
reason that tatsumaki became a hero it
is explained in the manga that it is
impossible for the hero association to
order blasts to do anything he only
performs acts of heroism of his own free
will he refuses to be bound by anyone
and hates being in the limelight and yet
despite of all that the hero association
decided that he is worth giving special
treatment stich believes that when
Humanity is in peril and must be saved
blast will surely take action although
everything about his powers is kept
secret
he believes that he is stronger than
King is presented to be can shoot lasers
from his eyes rules over psychic powers
and has the ability to command trillions
of robots
she speculates that blast could beat the
rest of the s-class all at once
obviously this is pure speculation and
will likely be proved false but it
illustrates the legend of blast power if
anyone can even hope to put up a
somewhat decent fight against Saitama
it's gotta be blast the number one hero
and that is it for today's topic thank
you so much for watching let me know if
you like seeing one punch man content on
this channel I'd love to hear from you
this video provided a brief overview of
the s-class heroes but if you want to go
in-depth on a particular one just leave
me a message in the comments if you
enjoyed the video smash that like button
to let me know if you haven't make sure
to subscribe and ring that notification
bell so you don't miss any new one punch
man videos a big thank you goes out to
our patrons over on patreon who help
make videos like this one possible I
especially want to thank our pro hero
tier patrons the one and only Gilgamesh
nothing but a fan Jason Wilson and Kings
eldress and are the one to your patrons
the ones who stay atop all clans baby
Rey a17 ffvp Steven and Radha alo long
autumn Mattie Mac 239 and makoto-kun and
the super special patient whose
greatness cannot even begin to be
fathomed regan Harrison the one who has
been acknowledged by Lord we go senpai
sama himself if you enjoy our work and
it gives you value you can support more
of it by going over to patreon comm
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as $1 if you do so you'll
get your name featured in future videos
alongside these s-class people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron Olney discord
so check out patreon.com/lenguin if
you're interested anyways thanks again
for all your support and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]